alguien te ha dicho que las
multiplicaciones son sumas abreviadas
pues es verdad las sumas y las
multiplicaciones son una especie de
compañeras matemáticas que nos ayudan a
agregar una cantidad a otra si te fijas
el signo de suma y el signo de
multiplicación no son tan diferentes y
entre los dos se llevan muy bien la
multiplicación llega cuando tenemos que
sumar muchas veces un mismo número la
clave está en que la suma sea de números
iguales
si en nuestra suma tenemos algún número
que no sea igual a los demás entonces ya
no podremos multiplicar para convertir
una suma en una multiplicación basta con
tomar el número que se suma muchas veces
y contar cuántas veces se repite en este
caso contamos el número de veces en el
que aparece el número 4 en la suma son
45 veces
así la multiplicación sería 4 por 5 que
es igual a 20 es importante que distinga
qué tipo de palabras se utilizan en
situaciones de suma y cuáles en las de
multiplicación porque aunque son muy
amigas si puede cambiar mucho el
resultado recuerda que las partes que
componen a la suma se llaman sumandos y
la cantidad que tenemos como resultado
se llama suma o total
la multiplicación tiene factores y de
cariño le decimos producto al resultado
vamos a poner dos columnas con las
palabras que se relacionan con cada
operación
así que del lado de la suma estarán las
situaciones donde debemos agregar
poner
su mar
juntar o aumentar dos o más cantidades y
para la multiplicación tendremos
sumas repetidas veces
multiplicar
obtener un producto o el producto de
factores si cada día nos dan cuatro
pesos para ahorrar y al final de la
semana queremos saber cuánto dinero
hemos ahorrado lo podemos solucionar
sumando el dinero de cada uno de los
días 4 de lunes 4 del martes + 4 del
miércoles
pero es un poco tardado lo más rápido y
fácil es multiplicar cuatro pesos por
los siete días de la semana 4 por 7 son
en este tipo de situaciones es mejor
usar la multiplicación porque son sumas
repetidas del mismo número
si queremos juntar nuestros ahorros de
la semana con los de un amigo para
comprar algo juntos debemos hacerlo con
una suma ya que se trata de juntar dos
cantidades si nosotros tenemos 28 pesos
y él tiene 30 sumamos 28 más 30 para
poder obtener 58 juntos tendremos 58
pesos
es cuestión de poner atención a los
problemas que nos piden y decidir qué
operación aplicar no es lo mismo a sumar
que multiplicar
solo si tenemos 22 es lo mismo que dos
por dos si lo hacemos con 33 nos va a
dar 6 y 3 por 3 es igual a 9 y con
cualquier otro número los resultados
serán muy diferentes así que ten cuidado
en qué signo usas y cooperación vas a
realizar porque el resultado será
diferente con cada una